après l'opéra après la comédie française
au cinéma voilà que la peinture débarque
dans nos salles obscures au programme de
ce mois de mai cézanne et
l'impressionnisme américain à nouveau
concept une nouvelle façon de s'immerger
dans la ville de ces artistes hors du
commun à nouveau plaisir aussi à vivre
sur grand écran le vrai cézanne est
extrêmement difficile à saisir
parce que si on se réfère effectivement
première année en tout cas de sa
carrière de peintre il doit trouver sa
place dans un milieu parisien d'avant
garde et il trouve sa place notamment
devant le cercle de man est depuis
quelques jours le cinéma des carmes
propose à ces cinéphiles des
documentaires autour de la peinture un
nouveau concept qui a démarré avec une
personnalité hors du commun celle du
peintre impressionniste paul cézanne
je trouve que c'est un concept très
intéressant et c'est une façon de
renouer avec le plaisir de la salle
c'est à dire que qu'est ce qu'on a à
offrir au public du cinéma certes et
aussi la possibilité de voir de belles
images sur de grands écrans en fait un
nouveau concept qui nous invitent
également au voyage
direction les états unis avec le jardin
d'artistes on ne le sait pas toujours
mais beaucoup de peintres américains ont
été influencés par le courant
impressionniste français
certains ont même séjourné à giverny
là où le peintre claude monet a vécu et
travaillé trois ans
l'intérêt de ce petit de ce film c'est
que il ya aussi une remise en contexte
historique géographique de l'essor des
états unis au 19e siècle
l'influent des impressionnistes français
sur les impressionnistes américains
comment c'est arrivé là-bas il ya
vraiment quand je dis on vous raconte
des histoires on vous raconte des
histoires
l'occasion aussi d'entrer dans
l'intimité des plus grands musées
américains de pennsylvanie au
connecticut
un voyage hors du temps à la gloire des
plus grands d'autres idées de sorties on
commence avec la fanfare saugrenue
formation jazzy à la fois conviviale
salon très festive ce collectif haut en
couleur et joyeusement baroque et un peu
barré rendez-vous chinon pour les
retrouver
[Musique]
autre groupe autre promesse d'une soirée
explosive
les écoliers débarquer la pasta c'est il
mélange de danse de cascades d'arts
martiaux d'humour et de poésie
un show incroyable
autres sont comment dire plus musclée et
plus énervés les américains de los
angeles les black mambas se feront
escale à orléans pour une soirée funk
plein de décibels bien sûr choisir un
gouverneur aux bretons de merveilleux
acteurs pour une pièce magistrale le cid
de corneille
le metteur en scène belge yves beaunesne
a choisi les versions de 1637
ce qui n'enlève ni la fougue ni la
jeunesse et on termine avec l'étoile de
richard boutin se montargois n'a pas son
pareil pour nous parler du temps qui
passe
une technique maîtrisée une peinture
intemporel et une esthétique très
personnel dépêchez vous c'est le dernier
week-end où il expose à beaugency
[Musique]